los presidentes de francia y manuel
macro ni estados unidos joe biden
esperan con este encuentro pasar página
al problema que se suscitó en septiembre
pasado cuando australes de renunció un
contrato millonario que había firmado
con una empresa francesa para comprar
unos submarinos y a cambio inicie un
contrato con una empresa estadounidense
recordemos que eso pensó las relaciones
al punto de que el canciller francés
calificó a joe biden de donald trump sin
tuits pero luego ambos presidentes se
llamaron por teléfono el secretario de
estado de eeuu blinken visitó parís y en
noviembre se espera que la
vicepresidenta eeuu kamala harris visite
también la capital francesa porque como
nos dicen desde el entorno al presidente
manuel macro a pesar de los entredichos
históricos que han tenido ambos países
siempre
permanece esa alianza histórica entre
francia y eeuu porque los intereses
comunes son más importantes es el
presidente manuel macrón quien recibe
aquí en la villa buena parte la embajada
de francia frente a la santa sede a su
homólogo estadounidense dicen para que
se vea que es eeuu en realidad quien
tiene interés de arreglar los asuntos
como asumiendo de cierta forma su
responsabilidad pero también al
presidente macro no le interesa dar la
tranquilidad a washington ya que el
próximo año francia asume la presidencia
semestral de la unión europea y el
presidente francés quiere poner en
práctica su europa de la defensa pero
demostrar a eeuu que eso no excluye una
cooperación militar transatlántica a
través de la otan además dicen aquí que
el presidente macrón espera gesto de
eeuu concretamente la cooperación de
washington en la lucha antiterrorista en
el sahel y también el respeto de la
posición francesa predominante en la
región indo pacífica